here's a neat math trick which fraction  is larger 5 over 8 or 8 over 13. to  solve this problem all you have to do is  cross multiply 13 multiplied by 5 is  equal to 65 and 8 multiplied by 8 is 64.  since 65 is larger than 64 5 over 8 is  larger than 8 over 13 and that's it  now you might be wondering why this  trick works let's imagine putting the  fractions with a common denominator  we'll multiply the numerator and  denominator of 5 over 8 by 13 and we'll  multiply the numerator and denominator  of 8 over 13 by 8. then we can calculate  the numerator of the first fraction is  65 and the numerator of the second  fraction is 64. since these fractions  have a common denominator we can of  course compare them and now we can see  we don't really need to compute the  denominator we can just compute the  numerators and we can see that 65 is  larger than 64 and that's why 5 over 8  is larger than 8 over 13.